a father facing deportation is taking
refuge this morning inside a Phoenix
church hey Suz Baroness has been ordered
to surrender to immigration officials
today his five-year-old son is battling
leukemia and his wife is five months
pregnant
Manuel Bojorquez is at the Phoenix
Church that opened its doors to Baroness
Manuel good morning good morning it's
not the first time this church has
housed an undocumented immigrant six
other people have reportedly sought
shelter here since 2014 his sous Bironas
is the latest he's asking ice not to
deport him a third time I will fight to
stay here his sous Bironas is son Jayden
is so scared his father will get
deported he refuses to leave his side at
the shadow rock United Church of Christ
the five year olds leukemia treatments
are too toxic for his mother to handle
my wife cannot give him the pills
because she's pregnant Bironas is his
family's sole breadwinner and the u.s.
is the only country he's ever known his
parents brought him here as a toddler in
1989 now 30 Bironas doesn't meet the
requirements for a so-called dreamer to
even apply for a green card he would
first have to leave the US for ten years
I have DUI I haven't no buddy there has
to be a price to pay right yes what
would you say to someone who doesn't
agree with you staying they don't like
our people like Mexicans Bironas says he
was once caught driving without a
license
he's been deported twice in 2006 and
2010 each time he came back illegally
even making the dangerous crossing
through the Arizona desert to be with
his wife and five children who are all
US citizens his kids need him
I need Oh Sonia Bironas five months
pregnant now worries about finding a job
to make ends meet have you thought about
what it would be like to have to say
goodbye to him on Thursday Immigration
and Customs Enforcement denied Bironas
latest attempt to stay his case is still
under review and he found paradise
Reverend Ken heinzelmann opened his
church doors to Bironas Friday some
would say you're harboring a criminal he
shouldn't be
kid he should be lifted up used as an
example of what it means to be a father
ice declined to comment to CBS this
morning for this story ice agents could
legally enter the church with a warrant
to seize Bironas but the agency
typically stays away from houses of
worship as it considers them sensitive
places John Manuel thanks